could you be successful in politics oh
yeah yeah almost definitely yes I I'm
gonna run for governor yeah I'm going to
run for governor in Oregon
eventually so sooner rather than later I
would have already ran by now I got yeah
I got caught up yeah you got your little
situation yeah in my situation yeah so
so let me rob banks in case is that
where we avoided saying I used to rob
banks oh wow yeah that's pretty good at
it really it was pretty good how much
money I did 15 points
allegedly I mean that's that's what they
allowed that's a Forbes yeah
yeah
anyway I got I got distracted there but
yes I would I would like uh politics for
fun yeah yeah I enjoy politics you would
be terrifying thank you you'd also be
like a great Handler in politics go on
like you could take a guy who's kind of
an empty vessel and you can fill him
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you could chess
piece because I think that's what I'm
learning like the the kind of older I
get and maybe the more this is gonna
sound crude but it's not meant to be
like but like the more money I get I
talk to people who have like real money
and the way they talk about politicians
is like they're just pawns sure and I
don't see you as someone who wants to be
kind of moved around a chessboard for a
few billionaires sure I don't assume
that it doesn't seem like that's what
you would aspire to be yeah politically
yeah and they're right they are I mean I
know what you mean I write those same
checks every election cycle but it's
it's for Access yeah and I needed it
plenty of times and I've made plenty of
phone calls and okay so there's certain
guys they're just the empty vessel and
they can communicate really well you
just give them the words and they get it
out there and it works have you ever
thought about
I like to participate I go when those
fundraisers come to Tech Kevin McCarthy
was just down just by example
um so I have fun like I I like I like
that world but uh most people don't they
find it boring but I find I I think
politics are interesting I've never seen
a football game I've never seen a
basketball game my uncle won an Olympic
championship for this country of
basketball and two NBA championships and
I've never seen a basketball game and it
drives him crazy who's your uncle Mel
counts okay uh Olympics at 64 in Tokyo
uh one for the Celtics and 65 and the 67
but
um I've never seen it but I've seen
every political debate there is I've
seen every presidential debate primary
debates who's the best Senator debates
it would come down I mean if you wanted
to have a real Face-Off between uh Bill
Clinton and Barack Obama that would be
something very special but but but Trump
can go head-to-head with any of them oh
I think Trump washes all them on the mud
slinging yeah it's the question is what
are they gonna do with the mudsling how
do you neutralize the Mudslinger I saw
Clinton do something once it was really
impressive he had like some people that
were boycotting his it was a speech or
something like that just some people
like ran into a room started boycotting
and he was trying to answer what they
were saying and he said one line he was
like uh those who don't listen are
afraid of the truth and they just shut
up wow and I was like oh that was a bar
Life's good he was he was good so like
remove politics Democratic Republic I
don't give a [__] who you are just
looking at like the fight game sure if
you're looking at the character They're
all playing oh yeah and he was [__]
good Obama was Obama was good though he
was special Trump has the Trump has the
nuke right he is like he is the overhand
right yeah that's what he has he's like
he might not have the skills he might
not have to do actually the political
thing but if he's on the stage with you
he ruined Jeb Bush's political life rear
telling him you have low energy yes I've
never seen it and then we tried to pick
up the other thing it was embarrassing
oh it was embarrassing it was it yeah it
was unbelievable no that was a different
way and I remember Jeb coming out and
telling people it was his pocketed
response because I heard him give it on
eight different networks and he says you
cannot insult your way to the presidency
and I'm like you dumb son of a [__] you
sure can he's about to he's in first
place Jeb yeah you're in eighth place
and you were the front runner yes you
can were you watching that like uh you
watch Fighters start to play yes and how
early on did you see the the momentum
when he came down those escalators wait
really he came down the escalators and
he said you knew him from The Apprentice
well I knew of him I was crony's war
with with Junior than I was of the old
man I'd only met the old man once and it
was in passing I I yeah I was in a mob
of people and I yelled yeah and I said
big fan and he shook my hand he goes
thank you but there you know there was
100 other people doing it you know
that's I'm I'm grabbing for for uh wait
uh I'm doing whatever you call you know
uh name dropping yeah but here here was
the thing with him he came down those
escalators and he took to the microphone
and Mitt Romney had just gotten beat and
Mitt Romney got beat because he was a
phony was very rich but he wanted to
pretend he was a man of the people he
eats KFC and he watches NASCAR I mean he
really ran from the money and Obama used
it against him he's like I don't have
anything I'm just like all of you I went
to Community College yeah yeah and I
it's like well that's weird
you should aspire to and Trump is part
of his opening day said uh I'm not gonna
take any money I'm gonna fund it myself
I'm really rich I will tell you that but
I remember what he did I remember when
he claimed I'm really rich it's exactly
what buried the Republican that came
before him he was rich and couldn't
admit it and Trump went right for it I'm
gonna call it out right now I am really
rich I will tell you that yes he was
even even accused of embellishing his
will I mean he went for it so hard for
everything that so if instead of saying
here's this rich guy he can't relate to
you people start going yeah well he's
not that right he's not even that rich
show your tax returns whoa you're not
even that rich it was the exact opposite
I saw the power of his wealth and they
tried to reduce it by questioning it
instead of ostracizing him for being 100
yeah interesting which coming on the
heels of Mitt Romney which a lot of
people want to know but I follow
politics it was just it was so different
I was like oh my gosh he he gets it and
he's going to win Jesse Ventura when he
ran you know Jesse Jesse Ventura is
nothing short of a kook
but I would steal a lot of what Jesse
Ventura did I mean on opening day out in
Minnesota
he won and he comes out and he says he
says yeah I've used cocaine I've gotten
prostitutes and I'm running for governor
who's got the first question and I
remember sitting there going son of a
[__] that was amazing and it did it was
in eight miles yeah yeah and you know
but I would see myself as that same
regard I'm going to come out just like
Ventura just like Trump would come right
with it and they even asked Ventura this
was another great thing that he did they
asked him because don't forget a
politician can only do two things they
can regulate in tax like you'll see
politicians say I'm going to create jobs
like you can only regulate in taxes the
only two functions you have and neither
regulation or taxation is good for job
growth so it's just a really dumb thing
to say you're going to create jobs but
they do make the claim and I will share
for you they ask Ventura what are you
going to do and they were in a law
library which is just stacked with books
and nobody knows what's even in all
those books and Ventura said don't you
think we have enough rules he said I'm
going to take a few of those books off
the shelf and I'm going to burn them I'm
going to get we need less laws around
here and he didn't go in he didn't
reduce any laws or he didn't do anything
that he said he was going to do but it
was a great point we do have enough damn
rules we really don't need anybody going
to the state or the cat and tell us more
things that we have to do yeah that
really is true we do need to lighten it
up how high up would you aspire to go as
high as you could go or you'd be happy
being a senator or Governor yeah maybe a
diplomat to Brazil I was going to I was
going to run for the presidency right
yeah as a diplomat that's funny I was
going to run for the president like when
I was growing up on the first day of
class they would they would make you
write your name and then you'd have to
say what you want to be when you grow up
and I would always write president of
the United States wow wow yeah I wrote
that since like third grade I remember
writing that my senior year in Mr Darius
every year I wrote president of the
United States